i never saw it coming
end of an era
yeah
hey guys pete here what seems like years
ago now show runner peter gould promised
viewers that the final season a better
call saul would change the way we saw
breaking bad forever i never doubted him
for a minute because why would i this
team has pretty consistently earned my
trust but i also didn't expect how
thorough of a job they were setting out
to do a couple hours after finishing fun
and games my head is still spinning
while i connect the dots i didn't love
what happened in this episode but i did
love how it happened i loved the way it
was set up i loved watching the
characters go through it and i suppose
most importantly i love the absolute and
unconditional clean break can i pull out
a much maligned bravo vince here because
one of the other favorite responses in
relation to the show which would bring
you an equal amount of vitriol was to
ponder if any certain thing that he did
was the moment jimmy mcgill turned into
saul goodman and then they just did it
they paired it with one of the most
expert time jump edits i've ever seen
and then it was done hi there saul
goodman nice to meet you it's all fun
and games until someone gets hurt
the thing this show has done better than
anything that came before it is to
deliver the inevitable in a way that's
still thrilling to watch we know where
things are going and we'd rather craft
elaborate theories that would explain
how it might turn out differently rather
than accept what we're about to see we
know that jimmy and saul exist inside
the same person but don't want to see
him change we know kim has to leave him
for that to happen but would rather
she'd stay we believe mike is different
than his cohorts but don't see as much
of that in breaking bad and i could go
on they made us want things to be
different while never not telling us
exactly how they'd be this episode's
ending actually begins in the last one
when lalo and howard are buried together
under the future super lab there are
some obvious takeaways built into that
scene it's a visual representation of
the two sides of the story coming
together there's a lawyer laying next to
the cartel it's awful that howard ends
up that way buried next to his killer
nonetheless and you can't miss mike's
regret as he tells his guys to take it
easy with the body we know mike's
discomfort is about howard not being in
the game it doesn't fit with the code
that he's crafted to help make his
working with gus make sense the other
layer here is that no code can account
for the world of destruction that what
they do brings people make choices for
what seem like good reasons mike wants
to provide for his daughter-in-law and
his granddaughter because he can't
forgive himself for not being able to
protect his son he copes with what he
believes he has to do by trying to
dictate how far he'd go while he's
pursuing that but in a way he's just
lying to himself fast forward to him
trying to do the right thing by going to
visit manuel varga and tell him about
his son nacho someone who by the end
mike truly cared for when he tells him
that he fell in with some bad people but
was never liked them not really he had a
heart he's basically describing what he
thinks about himself papa varga is able
to deliver a truth that might conceive
but not accept there is no justice in
killing nacho's killers because it's
just about revenge it doesn't change
what happened and what's worse is that
it doesn't deliver resolution the next
thing leads to the next thing and it
never ends i believe it's likely that
the better part of mike understands this
and that means that in breaking bad he's
making a conscious decision to overlook
that it's a hell of a way to bring his
better call saul story to an end we know
where his story goes from here and this
moment with manuel will paint a lot of
his choices in a different light this is
something that i'll come back around to
but if we're talking about revenge we
might as well talk about what his boss
was up to in this episode
gus is summoned for a quick trip to
mexico where he crushes hector one more
time as balsa was reading his letter i
found myself wondering just how long it
would take for him to dictate that to
the cousins and to compare that to how
long eladio took to dismiss it in favor
of his top earner lalo did such a good
job of setting up his fake death that he
made his uncle look like a delusional
jealous crank that wasn't getting his
way hector isn't the type of character
that you feel bad for after all he
relished killing max in front of gus a
few feet away from where they are but
you do still feel something as the sound
of his ringing bell fades as he's
carried away gus defeated lalo and he
got away with it we see that start to
set in and we see him do something we've
never seen before he goes out to
celebrate he has a pleasant uplifting
conversation about fine wine that's
packed with sexual tension and it's a
complete reversal from the paranoia he's
been living with throughout this season
he has the money bottle of wine at home
that's just waiting to be shared and he
does allow himself to entertain that
fantasy only for a minute though before
his friend returns he pays up and leaves
and that felt like the conclusion of his
involvement in this prequel we know how
single-minded his purpose is we know
where that takes him and as much as this
show did to make him a little scarier a
little more sociopathic i feel like this
made his character a little more sad
he'll give up everything else to get
what he wants and he'll be successful in
making the cartel and the salamanca
family pay and just like this
potentially hot romance here he'll never
get to enjoy it in relation to their
plan against howard kim and jimmy also
got what they wanted they made him look
bad and they got away with it but their
victory came with a very real unintended
consequence that led to him being in
that hole at the end of episode 8. in
the season's first montage we watch as
they're more or less able to go back to
their lives in the wake of that disaster
as mike and his guys make their
apartment look like it never happened
after they come home they briefly move
into a hotel that happens to have the
same painting above the bed that walt
commented on when he first met uncle
jack and when jimmy parrots mike's
advice from last season that he got from
stacy and their group back in season 3
there's a sense that they may be able to
put the whole thing behind them it's not
until they return to hhm that we get to
take their temperatures and it turns out
they're ice cold on the way in jimmy
says they can get through 20 minutes of
anything and based on a reddit comment i
saw i went back and checked and if you
skip ahead 20 minutes from where he says
that you'll see saul in a silk robe
managing his comb over in the mirror
howard's memorial is a high stress
affair presumably everyone who knew and
loved him is there i feel like the actor
who played ernesto must not have been
available for this because this would
have been the perfect time to show that
he's moved on and is thriving after his
situation with chuck we do get a final
scene with rich schweikart and it's
funny in a way that they have all these
mounted pictures around that look like
they could be from patrick fabian's
personal instagram account things get
heavy when they go to pay their respects
to his wife cheryl she brings up that
her husband told her that jimmy was
harassing him which we saw howard do in
her brief appearance back in episode 6.
it's not a surprise that jimmy can
deflect the accusations while appearing
to be earnest and respectful he knocks
it out of the park just like you'd
expect still cheryl can't believe howard
was on drugs and starts to get upset
this creates a situation where kim has
to step up with a lie that goes above
and beyond she comes up with exactly
what's needed while at the same time
it's something you'd never want this
character to be involved with she
doesn't just make up a story that never
happened which ends up being
corroborated by cliff's inability to
answer which of course is related to
their scam but when cheryl starts to
believe it she leans in to pretend she's
on her side and well that's difficult to
watch and i think what's worse than the
aftermath of what their choices have led
to all of this that's happening in these
last couple of episodes what's worse is
that they're just so damn good at doing
this
as they go out to the parking garage we
get a glimpse of the spot where we first
saw them interact in that famous scene
in the first episode of the series and
then jimmy tries to put a positive spin
on things
then we get what i think is the best
race seahorn as kim seen in the entire
series i know recency bias but in this
shot where she doesn't say anything
where she just looks at her husband and
contemplates what he just said before
she moves closer to kiss him i knew that
it was over it takes a second to hit but
it feels impossible to miss not to be
outdone bob odenkirk does a fantastic
job of letting us see that jimmy knows
it too after she drives away even if
he's not ready to accept it because
we're not ready to either they give us a
courtroom scene to drive it home ever so
slowly by the time the judge has just
about had it with her not wanting to
move forward with her current case kim
admits that she's no longer a lawyer at
first i was confused about why she made
this step if you don't want to practice
fine but why make it official i think
this comes back to the idea of justice
that we heard papa varga bring up part
of this quest to take down howard was
born in the belief that kim could decide
who deserves it what's a career setback
for a powerful lawyer in comparison to
all the help that she could give to
underprivileged people and she wasn't
necessarily wrong all things considered
tipping the scales in the other
direction would amount to some good and
even howard realized that he would
bounce back before he died i think she
realized the part that manuel pointed
out to mike that it never ends and when
things go as wrong as they did and you
have to live with the consequences of
your choices you can't continue to tip
the scales to try to make up for it
jimmy races home after he gets the news
that she withdrew from the bar and i
liked how they showed us that her mind
was made up as she calmly watches him
pull into this parking spot and then
mostly just listens as he freaks out
it's hard to watch for us but his
reaction is to be expected when he
bursts into their room to see that she's
packing to leave she brings up him
asking if he was bad for her and if you
recall that scene that's where she
decided that she was gonna do something
to try to lift his spirits which
eventually sets things in motion for
going after howard she assures jimmy
that that's not the problem that the
truth is that they're bad for each other
and when he starts to buckle under the
weight she says jimmy i have had the
time of my life with you but we are bad
for everyone around us other people
suffer because of us apart we're okay
but together we're poison this is
followed by a wonderfully painful bit of
pleading that ends with jimmy finally
saying i love you for the first time on
screen and this is where you see her
break a little as she tears up and says
but so what and as devastating as this
is i think it shows how genuine their
feelings are for each other it doesn't
play like this is his first time ever
saying this out loud and her coming back
with us so what i think it drives home
the idea that they say it to each other
all the time off screen and that this
breakup isn't about them not feeling
that way anymore they went out of their
way to show just how real that was in
the last episode and this conversation
and her reasoning for the breakup all
reinforces that it's not tragic because
they're falling out of love it's that
way because they are in love and you
understand that they'll continue to feel
that way but they can't be together if
that wasn't enough when pushed about
what happened to howard not being her
fault kim confesses that she knew she
tells him that she kept this a secret
because she knew what he'd do and that
would lead to them breaking up which is
something she didn't want because she
was having too much fun on some level
jimmy understands this and realizes
there's nothing else he can say we just
watched his heart crumble from behind as
she goes to the room and finishes her
packing it's the scene i was joking
about in the beginning and after that
incredible jump to him waking up on a
rotating bed with a sex worker we know
his transformation is complete this
flash forward is more than a stinger it
fully immerses us in the breaking bad
timeline before the episode ends there's
a lot of interesting stuff going on but
the real point is that this is what his
life looks like behind the scenes it's
something that we never got to look at
in the original series and it works
really well to show how different he is
now that kim is no longer in his life it
makes sense when you look at everything
that happened and if you ever thought
during the series that you couldn't wait
to get saul back how do you feel about
it now i doubt that we've seen kim for
the last time there's the obvious chance
of her coming back during the gene
timeline and i think it's possible that
with four episodes to go that there
could be even some scenes to show what
her post-albuquerque life looks like for
saul we're crossing over into old
territory but it still feels like
anything could happen plus there's still
that call on his birthday that he
mentioned in the 405 teaser at this
point she still seems like the most
likely person to be calling which means
that they aren't completely out of
contact i thought they did a fantastic
job of hitting each point on the way to
this conclusion you hate to see it but
it was amazing to watch using mike and
gus to show where revenge and this
skewed sense of justice takes you and
then bringing it all back around to
kim's choices worked so much better than
you would have guessed it could as it
became clear that kim would probably not
be around past this episode i was at a
place where i didn't like any of the
options partly because i didn't want the
relationship to end but more because
most of the popular ones will require
something drastic to happen at best or
at worst have someone or something make
that decision for her i truly appreciate
that they decided to go with the idea
that a character can be more than one
thing at the same time i think that this
totally tracks with the kim we've gotten
to know even though she was so committed
to the scam she seemed proof that jimmy
would never be able to do it and i think
part of what's always been interesting
about these two is that despite being
unbelievably capable on their own they
still needed each other it makes it
tough to watch her make this decision
knowing that and if you can't be sure
where it leads or knowing what this
might do to this person that she cares
about at least you can say that she did
what she had to do by herself and i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about the episode what you
think about the time jump and if we seen
the last of kim this is the type of
episode that the more i think about it
the more it reveals it just keeps going
so make sure you join us for the live
stream tuesday at 9 00 pm eastern time
because i'm sure there'll be a lot more
to say when we get there please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon